this is a talk called slot than envy and
the sloth part is in part it took me a
very long time to put this talk together
the envy part you'll see what that's all
about
now just to get started we're at pied it
at new york it's Tuesday November 5th
2019 add some you know posterity to
these talks in case somebody wants to
watch this you know in five years when
I'm long gone yeah I'll give it four
years I'll go to four years
I'm James Powell if you like this talk
you can follow me on Twitter I'm don't
use this code I give other similar talks
honestly when I tried to figure out what
you should do if you like this talk I
couldn't come up with a slide so that's
a good I hope that's a good I hope
that's a good endorsement now I want to
start with a little thought experiment
did you know that the software that you
use and you're a blip on every single
day was written and designed by just
some person and did you know that the
software that you use and rely upon
every day has code that you could read
and you could just fully understand it's
not that hard it's not that difficult in
many cases it's just a lot of code it's
time-consuming and did you know that the
software that you use and may rely upon
every single day probably was written in
C or has some portion C and so if that
was the case the system v ABI would
specify there were three possibilities
for the entry point for that
and when I say entry point I mean the
int main and when I say three
possibilities I mean you can either have
an int main with nothing in it we're
gonna have an int main with an int and a
car star array or you can have this with
the last car star at the end you might
wonder what that is and so if you look
at the full signature the full signature
would say that that last argument is an
MP it's a pointer to your environment
and when you look at this you might say
that's kind of interesting I've never
seen that signature before and hold on a
second isn't there a typo there and
actually there's not cuz I pulled this
from the docs this is the actual docs
for the system v ABI and what I was
looking at I was wondering is that
really a typo
I suspect it's just the system v abi abi
authors being apolitical unfortunately I
don't expect anybody to get that joke
really I don't
and so let's take a look at some
interesting things when I talk about
environment what do I mean well I mean
the thing when you type in a bunch of
junk pops up on your screen and you
might have seen that before you know if
you want to see what it really is
this is a little bit of a closer view
from your pocket file system it's just a
giant set of null-terminated strings
where each string has an equal sign
summer in it and the first part of the
string is some key and the other part of
the string is some value it's some key
value store that each program has access
to and you might be familiar with at
least one of these things in your end
your path what is your path Ford
identifies what happens when you type
the name of a binary that gets run when
you want to run something and if you
look at your path it's just a colon
separated set of directories which gives
rise to the very first question for this
talk what if you have a directory with a
colon and its name that you want to add
to your path the answer is there is no
answer you can't do that
now you may be familiar with this path
because you might have some point tried
to figure out where's my Python which
Python my using my system Python am I
using my Python my Conda and I'm using
my Python in my virtual lamp and you
would have typed with which Python and
you might have even typed which which oh
no not that one which user bin which oh
well not that one that's kind of
pointless and you want to figured out
that you know there's actually a program
called which that goes through and tries
to identify which two all you're using
by searching through your path and this
is what that program looks like this is
would see from a package called which
was just written by some guy and if you
look through this you can kind of tell
that it's like a new package whose look
at all these pointless options that it
has because you really need a lot of
command line flags when you're trying to
figure out which binary you're running
out of your path and if you look through
this you might see that it's actually
quite straightforward there's just a
function called path search that just
searches through your path by taking
that environmental variable splitting it
on the equal sign splitting the right
hand side of the equal sign in a colon
and searching for the thing that you
wanted now you might also be familiar
with this because when you are working
with your virtual environment or your
condo environment you had this source
been activated you might have looked at
that source been activate and you would
have seen that all it really does is set
a bunch of environmental variables like
path or Python path or old virtual
Python home or some nonsense like that
and you might have seen recently on
Twitter there was a very nice blog post
by a colleague of ours
Brett Kanin about why you should always
say Python -
and pip install as opposed to just a pip
install and you might have wondered can
I do Python - M Conda install and the
answer is no you can't do that don't ask
me why
now the reason that you might do the two
of these is because when you think about
it the very first argument that you find
in your that you put on the command line
here is determined by your path and so
the Python 3.8 that you run could be the
Python 15 in your virtual lamp in your
Conda M at your system and your path
will determine which of the three that
you run if you type pip install the pip
that will you will be using to install a
package might be the one in your virtual
lamp might be the one in your condo end
might be the one in your system and it
may not be clear which one it is it may
be the case that you have pip on one of
your Python installs which doesn't
happen to be yeah somebody's side so
somebody's right into this which doesn't
happen to be the one that you and that
you intended to install the package in
so he did a pip install and then you
launched your Python interpreter they
were actually in completely different
paths and so you pip installed something
you tried to import it and you were very
confused and that's why they say always
do Python 3.8 - M install I hope you
didn't learn anything new
now if you look at this this is about
the signature for what you might see for
say a main function that happens to have
that third argument with the MP now this
is not altogether that interesting and
you might wonder well what do we do with
this MV where does it come from and so
if we take this binary and we
disassemble it we know that any C
program starts with a start symbol and I
run to a bunch of stuff and what edge of
the thing is this int main that you
write which can have three possible
signatures is not what actually runs
when you launch your binary what
actually runs is a Lib C start main that
then calls your main which is why you
have the ability to have three possible
signatures which may or may not throw
away some arguments now if we're curious
about what that Lib C start main was and
how we go from the process starting with
the environmental variables to being
able to use them we might look into the
source code for Lib C which looks kind
of like this and you can see here's the
entry point this is the actual code that
runs whenever a binary starts if you're
compiling it on Linux for x86
using Lib C and there's a bunch of
comments about what all these assembly
language instructions do and then
somewhere toward the end you can see
that it calls a main function and the
main function that it calls happens to
be a main function
happens to be a main function in or
actually happens to be an initializer
that's also in Lipsy and there's a bunch
of code here and eventually calls it
slips II start main that has all of
these arguments that we saw in the last
of the three possibilities and if you
scroll through this and look through
this code it's very ugly it's got a lot
of pipe deaths got a lot of underscores
and it but eventually you'll see a line
where somebody did something like this
they took the environment that was
passed to your program and they assign
it to a variable called n or called and
viral and then in your Python program
you are able to use it if we look at
this from the other end you know in your
Python program you can say from OS
import environ get em and put in and if
you look at the environ it's just a
dictionary with all the environmental
variables you can see this is a very
clean environment which is the land a
term and you have put em so you can add
in another environmental variable and
environmental variables are strings so I
can't say add one that's an integer I
have to turn it into a string like this
and if you look at that you can see oh
it's in my environment actually no it's
not because that doesn't work either if
you put something into your volume it
using put in you can't get it back out
using environ you have to get it back
out using get in and so again oh wait
that didn't work either so you can see
sometimes things don't quite work the
way you want them to work but if you dig
a little bit deeper you might figure out
why that might be and so if we look at
the source code for your OS module where
you ultimately get your own fire on your
get end and you're put in you might see
that on startup when this module is
first imported it does this create
enviro and if you look at that creative
I run you might see that all it is is a
dictionary subclass that makes it so
that when you assigned to that
dictionary it calls put end one of the
covers when you pull out of that
dictionary when you do a get item on
that dictionary it does get em under the
covers and if you dig a little bit
deeper and you figure out where those
get end and put em functions come from
you might see that there's a module if
you have any be Linux called your POSIX
module and in your POSIX module there's
one step when that is initialized that
creates an environment that takes that
environ variable that we just saw that
threaded through your program from the
initial entry point to your Lipsy start
main and converts it to a Python
dictionary there's actually two Python
dictionaries involved there's one at the
POSIX module level and one at the OS and
viral level and if you look through this
module you might see a bunch of other
things that you recognize like a get F
call that just calls get in so you have
a mirror
of what's happening in Python what's
happening in C but as a consequence of
your building these data structures and
Python that mimic these data structures
in C you sometimes have discontinuities
where if you use get in for put em and
OS dot environ you might find that you
put in a biomarker an environment build
a very an environmental variable in and
you couldn't get it back out
couldn't find now one thing that this
kind of one thing this kind of makes you
curious about is if in C there aren't
really data structures and when we
looked at our proc self and by Ron it
was just a giant contiguous piece of
memory of null terminated strings and
I'm Python it's a dictionary well
dictionaries are constant time lookup
and linear structures are linear time
lookup so wouldn't it be faster to write
a program in Python to look up
environmental variables and writing what
and see so here I have a very simple
program they just looked up an
environmental variable 10,000 times 1
and C and one in Python and we can
compare them because we're told in our
computer science classes that what's
more important than what language are
using the most important thing is your
Big O complexity your linear your linear
versus your constant comm complexity
right and so if we write a little test
program to test this out we can see that
if you compare Python versus C oh wait
actually it's much faster and C so it
turns out a lot of things are a lot
faster and C even ignoring the big o
time complexity those coefficients are
actually quite meaningful and in fact if
you look at the test results you can see
well not really because if you ignore
the blip at 10,000 it's much faster to
have a Python program if you have a
hundred thousand environments of herbals
so if you learn anything from this talk
it is if you have a program with a
hundred thousand environmental variables
then maybe Python is a good choice
because the Python dictionary has been
optimized quite well for this purpose
and that linear search you know the
constant factors eventually do catch up
to you now in a couple of examples if
you try to run this with more you'll see
a lot of noise here is twice as fast so
now we have a very clear use case for
Python and production those C
programmers can't tell us anything now
setting that aside one thing that you
might be kind of interested about is why
do we have get in
and it seems like we're going back to
the old Java days with getters and
setters like we know that if you have
some state in Python like some state
associated with their sis not pack you
do things like path dot append and it
actually goes and mutates that path
object in place but then you have this
discontinuity where if you have like the
recursion limit in the sis module you
have a get recursion limit and a set
recursion limit and you might say to
yourself well you know getters and
setters a kind of pass in Python that's
why we have properties right that's why
and and you might say you know this is
bad file but at the same time things
like get and set recursion limit predate
properties there from a long time ago
and you might say maybe that's even why
the map pilot API is the way it is
because in some cases it's old it
predates a lot of what we consider to be
modern Python in other cases it's that's
matplotlib you got 11 now but if you
look a little bit deeper you'll see that
this is actually quite consistent
because even in the fist module it's
something like get Co routine wrapper
and set co-routine wrapper there's still
a getter and a setter and we've been
told so many times getters and setters
that's not pythonic I wonder why that is
especially considering that in Python
3.7 with pet 562 we actually have module
level get adder in other words down here
if we have in a module a function called
get at our at the module scope and we
import that module we can do kind of get
at our behavior see we can implement
that so why wouldn't we just use get
module level get adder instead of
getters and setters
well the downside is we don't have a set
adder so we couldn't set anything with a
module but there's something much more
fundamental to all of this puzzle and it
comes back to a question that I always
ask whenever I do a corporate training I
always ask my class what's the
difference between from math import log
and import math math dot log what's the
difference between these two I'll pause
for a second to let you think which of
these is right well the answer is
neither is right because you can't take
the log of 0 that's a domain error but
what's the difference why does it matter
well it turns out that there's actually
a very fundamental difference there's a
real significant difference it's a very
subtle and it's a very minor and it ties
back to our environment store what's the
answer the answer is one of these is
early binding and one of these
in other words when you say from math
import law it's the exact same thing as
saying import math log equals math log
and loggers it'll give you the exact
same error at an exact same time but
what the meaningful difference here is
are you capturing the value of that
function as of the line when you did the
import or you capturing the value of
that function whenever you're calling
that function out of that mark are you
getting the most recent value for these
pieces and if you go back to these
examples you'll see something very
interesting in sis top path where is to
stop path use well it's only really used
in the internal machinery of the Python
import mechanism path is a list so it's
mutable and so to make it directly
mutate able is quite easy if you early
bind it that's fine because probably
somebody who should be modifying their
paths shouldn't say sis top path equals
path plus whatever they should be using
dot insert or dot append to directly
mutate it in case of early binding
occurred or in the cases of these three
these are mostly doing things like
setting functions which are immutable
objects and there could be a risk that
each one of these things could be used
in some third-party library summer could
have accidentally been early bound and
because they accidentally got early
bound you'd run up into very strange
anomalies in your program where an early
bound and late bound variable where
there's a class you thought you had said
something and hadn't actually gotten set
now how does this tie back to and well
it turns out that you never really know
when your sis not when you when your
environment variables are actually bound
they exist in that structure in your
main and your they exist as part of that
signature of your entry points part of
that signature of your main they could
have been copied from there you always
have the ability to access with the
original environment so variables and
were passed your program or you can do
put F operations to your heart's delight
but you really never really know if a
program at some point in time has done a
put F operation and if some other part
of that program at some point in time is
gonna do a get a operation or if it's
bounded at some point because you never
really know that there's one clear
guideline with environments where this
don't change them over the course of
your program when I put this slides
together the analogy that I came up with
that was widely hated by all the people
who heard it was that environmental
variables are kind of like react
he passed props down and everything's
immutable and so the answer is don't
change environmental variables in flight
environmental variable
are away processes to communicate under
a very strict set of conditions that
condition being they're set at starts
they're used during the program they're
only ever looked up and they're never
changed because you end up with strange
anomalies very similar to to your early
late binding problem in in Python when
you have environments where goals have
changed in flight you should only ever
pass environmental variables down to
child processes that you then launch as
opposed to change them as part of your
car classes which is quite unfortunate
because as part of this talk one of the
things that I wanted to do was I wanted
to show you the ability to change
environmental variables into a process
at runtime and it turns out it's quite
easy to do you can do a dot peep you can
you can use P trays to go into the
process of space and you can find
exactly where that environmental
variable structure is it's in it's in
your you know it's just in global memory
it's not that hard to find and if you
dig through the code for Lib C you can
even find that this is your Lib C for
set n is your leave sir this is your
Lipsey forget em and all it does is
operate on one global variable that you
have access to this is your library for
put ends and all it really does is look
at that same global variable this is
your library this is what it actually
calls and at the end of the day add to
envira and all it really does is operate
on one global variable called and by
wrong with two underscores at the
beginning you can mutate that to your
heart's of the light but since you never
really know when this is bound you can
never really guarantee that'll have any
effect in your program will actually
work and so taking that input in mind
and thinking about what did I learn over
this absolutely bizarre talk I want to
talk briefly about what the takeaways
are and when I was presenting these
notes to one of my colleagues who's in
the audience today one of the takeaways
that he suggested was you know what even
for a very small very minor problem that
nobody really thinks about something
that you just live with that's part of
your every single day life
there might be code behind it and you
could just go and read that code you go
with Lib C and so the answer is not you
can read through Lib C that is a
terrible takeaway Joe nobody wants to
look through through Lipsy nobody cares
the takeaway is I gave this talk the
wrong title I should have called it
long-form table thank you so much
I think we're right on time we got five
minutes until the next session right you
want anyone have any questions
that was so pointless wasn't it anyone
like the absolutely pointless benchmark
I was very proud that took me so long to
do
probably some kind of l1 caching thing
you're looking for these linear scans of
some some block of memory that is that
as soon as you're running on Windows
right I don't does anybody use Windows I
don't think so so there we go I think
we're just about to go into lightning
talks so I hope you enjoyed this this
little piece of fun I hope you've been
enjoying the conference so far I think
part of the reason that I give talks
like this is to show you that there is
some fun to be had in programming that's
not a message or a take away because
takeaways and messages are kind of
stupid and talks but it's just to tell
you that it's okay to not be altogether
too serious